this is another big one we know this
libraries don't last everyone talks
about the Library of Alexandria even
though that story you know is a little a
little different than the version we get
so let's just look at some of what's
what's lost here 55,000 books in
manuscript I just these are some random
ones that I've pulled up 170 thousand
volumes destroyed millions of books lost
in China and 400 C 8,000 rare books a
lot of these there were no other copies
these are gone forever to me when I was
growing up and I lost my way with my
religion and adopted science and wanted
knowledge and got into books and I found
out about these libraries that were lost
to me like this is worse than any loss
of human life because we're all gonna
die but to lose knowledge that we built
and and and would never have again plays
things like that was terrifying the good
news is I made all this long that'd mean
I mean motive that most of this up
yeah I actually just like wrote random
stuff the thing that I that the thing
that I kept though is what was lost
because these are the real dates and
places and this is just so this is just
a sampling these are the ones that we
know about these in the last few years
and this is what was lost
Isis is mauling our heritage right now
books are targets this is just to drive
home that point of what books are going
to be good for and that we have to get
back to this stage not where we can turn
power on but where we can open our minds
back up
[Music]